alors lequel et daniel lequel et
stéphane je suis daniel serre-chevalier
ah oui vous vous êtes l'employé du moi
c'est simple fictivement j'ai été
employé du mois pendant un an tu les as
entendu te demander raconte moi ta vie
pourrie chez univers tail 99 euros 1490
450 euros tu dois être un truc un peu à
la rhein man qu au dessus de la moyenne
en dessous ou autiste on va passer à la
télé c'est génial ça m'intéresse pas des
mille fois ils prêts à tout prix qui
nous a appelés à les sélectionner on
vient se faire virer on va peut-être
gagner cent mille balles bah oui doit
rien
on dit que vous chantez oui mais non je
ça j'arrête
chanter les gens qui sont seuls si
daniel quel beau brun ou les bikes
ok tout le monde en a un champion on
regarde les caméras sur lui
un talent fou retard était la musique
c'est donc l'histoire ça stephen sady
réfère le clip est simplement dan ok
mais tous forts pas tu devrais faire
attention daniel je trouve que tu t'en
prends vraiment vite
j'en veux
c'est quoi ce mec juste un pauvre type
qui rêvent déconner
j'ai pas si vous en avez conscience mais
vous avez un énorme potentiel
six films j'en ai conscience blessures
bon si c'est un clip c'est mon ne
veulent pas perdre et d'un grimm puck
laurent sniffera de l'aco que sur le
culte de 3 [ __ ] qui passent dans la
vague un matin